so uh this is kind of a standard title
for for my talk some combinations of
machine learning as they improving but
I'll try to sort of speak a bit a bit
more about what I was kind of asked uh
from the organizers like about like uh
AI for understanding mathematics Etc so
uh uh as you already heard like almost
some 30 years ago when I was studying
math I I started to ask these questions
like how how do I how do we automate it
right and obviously at that point you
you learn about all these
like undecidability and
um and um incompleteness results Etc but
like my my feeling still was that uh
what we are doing as as humans might not
be so un approachable to to to
machines and there was this field of
automated fear improving which is like a
very old like maybe one of the first uh
fields of AI so so by by the way that's
an answer to one of the questions given
to me by the organizers like what about
using AI for theor and proving well the
answer is that during the history of AI
CRM proving used to be AI it was
actually one of the first fields of AI
and there there are like these um
pendulum swings right like that suddenly
something totally different is
considered to be to be AI today but
maybe tomorrow theor proving maybe with
some combinations with other uh
algorithms will again be uh considered
to be AI so so I see see this as as one
kind of big landscape and uh so already
like when when I was thinking about this
like some 30 years ago it became to me
kind of indispensable that we have to
include learning like that what I'm
doing as a student of math is is somehow
learning from my successes and failures
and and this learning is kind of
informing my uh further uh attempts and
Explorations and that there are probably
some pretty complicated or maybe not so
complicated uh feedback groups about
like the exploration the
deduction and the the the learning um
that we we should be exploring so so
that as you heard that was kind of
already my master CES in which I was
using symbolic machine learning at that
point called inductive logic programming
which may again be pretty interesting
today especially in combination with
like the statistical machine learning uh
methods because it was kind of explosive
at the time in in the same way as for
example theorum proving was explosive
because the combinatorial search was big
but in in a similar way as we are today
sort of pruning the combinatorial search
by by the the Learned
experience uh in theor proving we could
also be be learning the search for
algorithms like crisp algorithms using
um statistical machine learning and I
think it's already happening and in like
Fields like program synthesis
Etc uh so um yeah so so this intro slide
is basically that we should
be exploring the these combinations of
uh learning and reasoning and
deduction and I I think both sides of of
this um of this equation are important
you you cannot just do learning like for
example today with with the kind of llm
Revolution or even before that people
were speaking about grounding the LM
llms in in some world uh knowledge right
but like in in in my opinion logic is is
the revolution that happened 100 years
ago that is kind of the most General way
of giving us some World models right
like how how do you express I don't know
physics theories or mathematical
theories like like thanks to the the
work that these people like Russell or
even liet did for us we we have a
very general way how to how to play
these these games with some with some
environment like we don't just play some
chess or go some some kind of boring
games but we we really can play the full
mathematical game right and that
includes physics and and all all of that
and I think the these people like poer
are actually talking about it when when
they are speaking about how how science
develops like we we do we build some
kind of World Knowledge some some
theories and then we try to break them
by pushing them to their limits like all
sorts of
stuff uh yeah
so so so so the thing where where I
could do these experiments already like
30 years ago are these corpora of formal
formal mathematics
which again was already pretty it's it's
a field that started like some 60 years
ago uh but already something like 30
years ago you you you got quite big uh
formalizations on which you could try
try to train some some combinations of
deductive and inductive methods and and
see how how far it will take you uh so
so that's kind of the
intro the there is a bunch of slides
quotes that I have collected over the
years so so p is one of the old old this
guys who who says that mathematicians
don't just do proving but they they also
use induction uh guessing Etc OB
obviously there is poer saying that the
hypotheses are NS Only You casts will
catch that that is po parall processing
that sucks
uh that says certainly let us learn
proving but also let us learn
guessing and
then will likely cause
problems oh
so so so there is this quote from uh
yeah p
oh let's
try um so that there is this quote by
Heming uh which is Galileo once says
mathematics is the language of Science
and facing the same loss of the physical
world alien mathematics must have a good
deal of similarity to to ours so so I'll
I'll pluck to it a bit later but what I
like about this quote is that some some
of the feedback loops that we are we
have been trying and running uh between
let's say learning and uh deduction or
so some other search methods have
already show shown us that the the
systems can lead to
nonhuman solutions that they can kind of
produce this Al alien mathematics so so
I think it may be also a bit relevant in
this era of of the llm where people
think like the llms will just learn
everything which is out on the internet
produced by
humans uh but but but but I think what
we are doing is much more interesting in
the sense that really these feedback
loops can can show us a lot of like
inhuman design spaces like like we can
really discover things which the humans
didn't discover like you already had it
in go for example right like the the
alpha go zero discovered some moves that
the professionals considered to be wrong
but like the alpha
zero convince them that they are not
wrong uh yeah I I have a bunch of funny
picture pictures stolen from log logicx
so so so just to show you the typical
tension between the detective and and
the sort of uh more I don't know
learning inductive camp this goes back
to panker versus
hbert uh where kind of pank argued that
um basically logic and formalism will
kill mathematical
induction
intuition uh then this is the other side
right like again from logic comic where
where Russell sort of quotes the the
liit uh dream as as dream to to
basically solve all our problems not
just mathematical ones but all all of it
like physics law economics Etc by
basically a reduction to to logic and
computation and this is Stefan so so we
started a conference called I and theor
proving like 10 years ago and Stefan
Schulz is one of the people who who was
doing machine learning and theor
improving even before me uh his PhD C
this is in equipping one of the best
automated theor improvs called e with uh
machine learning uh methods and then he
gave this funny talk at the first aitp
called deduction and induction a match
made in heaven or a deal with the devil
so um
yeah oh I I I don't want to speak too
much too abstractly so I put two quick
uh demos I I I don't know how how quick
they will be and I yeah uh so so so the
first quick intro or demo is this uh
proving learning feedback loop that we
do on a reasonably big uh for
mathematical Corpus of something like
60,000
problems uh and we kind of got it
working relatively recently in
2019 where we sort of zoomed in on
machine learning
methods that are both efficient like
they are not very slow and also quite
powerful uh that can be pluged into the
state of the art automated theor and
press so uh the thing with the
state-of-the-art automated theor press
is that these are really fast symbolic
solvers with a lot of very good
teristics for example I think until
today basically nobody has beaten the
highis stics in s solvers in in in the
um propositional uh uh like um logic
solvers with some deep planning because
that would make it really slow right
like so so the the let's say first order
or high of the medoran pr are not as
crazy efficient as SS but they are still
like very very efficient uh
symbolic uh symbolic solvers and guiding
them with something like Chad GPT would
be kind kind of silly because like if
you
ask let's say this symbolic solver does
I know 10,100 steps per per second and
if you want to guide each of these steps
by by some large language model then
then you would be in big trouble because
it would really slow it down a lot so so
you need to be a bit more efficient or
quite a bit more efficient with with the
machine learning guidance but like uh
such methods do exist in this case we we
took something called gradient boosted
decision threes which are ensembles of
decision threes and we took the
unmodified automated the pr ran it on
this 60,000 U uh problems from the M
mathematical library and initially with
the unmodified E we solved 15,000 of of
of these problems then we trained the
these efficient gradient boosted
decision trees on on on these 15,000 uh
problems and plugged them in a
reasonably efficient way to guide the
the kind of search done by by the
automated theor PR and run it again we
we run it in a kind of honest way so so
the automated the impr without the
guidance gets 10 seconds on a s single
CPU and the automated sh improv with the
guidance the guidance is run also on a
CPU gets also 10 seconds of of a CPU
time and with the guidance like in in
the first uh iteration with the guidance
we do it in two different ways but
that's not so important the the better
method jumps to something like 20,000 uh
solved problems thanks to learning from
these 15,000 problems so so then you can
train again that's kind of the iteration
that the feedback loop thing and plug
now the kind of more informed and and
smarter uh machine learning model again
into into this e and try to solve these
problems again in 10 seconds and and and
you get to something like 23,000 if you
iterate this I don't know six times in
this first experiment then it takes you
to something like 25,000 problems which
is something like a 70 uh% Improvement
so so this is like one of the kind of
prototypical examples of of of these
feedback loops
between uh the the proving the deduction
the the search and the learning which
kind of can guide the the the the search
and and the deduction we we pushed it
further when it started to work and then
put like also like graph neural networks
into it later getting us to something
like
75% of of the misar library eventually
in
2021 but with higher time
limits so so we can we can get proofs
like this this is in uh four minutes you
are not supposed to read it just to
impress you with the is the bigness of
the graph so this is like 360
step and this is how how that graph
looks when it's the proof written by the
human in the library again you are not
supposed to read
it this is my Victorious announcement
from 2021 when like I called it the rise
of the computronium at the time and this
was before llms before the Chad GPD
thing so so what what was kind of
interesting is that for a lot of these
problems in the M library you not only
need some kind of typical mathematical
reasoning steps like some kind of
natural Direction Stuff Etc but also
quite a lot of like algorithmic stuff
like I don't know matrix multiplication
or like integration and
differentiation uh various
normalizations Etc and it looked like
basically in this you could call it
during
complete theorem proving framework you
can basically get the feedback to to to
learn a lot of these not just reasoning
but also pretty focused algorithmic
tasks so so I like like one answer to
the question of like like what kind of
AI we we we need for doing math is that
um like you you can imagine this as some
kind of alternative to to this today's
world of llm will do at all is that you
have some huge formal knowledge like
huge formal data set and and you have
these kind of not so huge and in this
case this was graph newal Network or
graded and boosted decision trees which
basically tells you how to combine the
these pieces of of the formal knowledge
which by the way include the algorithmic
knowledge right so so it can really uh
do do these things uh this is the second
kind of intro demo example so it's an
experiment that we have been running for
two or three years now on the online
encyclopedia of integer
sequences and it's not strictly theorem
proving uh but it has this kind of
search uh
verification and learning uh aspects to
it so so so these graphs shows you uh
like the iterations of of this feedback
loop between the the search checking and
and learning so we are now well this was
in the summer of
24 on roughly 700 iterations of this
feedback loop and and on the yaxis you
you get the the number of the solt
sequences so so inis the the verion
which we are running has something like
350,000 integer sequences in it and you
can see that by the
700 we sold roughly 13 of it like about
120,000 so so the the feedback loop
looks uh
roughly like this um so we have a very
small C and complete uh domain spe
specific language for the programs that
uh we are
synthesizing uh so you can see two
examples here one one is 2 to the^ of X
which is this Loop 2 * X X1 and the X
factorial which is Loop y * X X1 so it's
a very short program and and in this
domain specific
language and we are initially randomly
or you could say also exhaustively that
doesn't matter uh
generating programs of of of this shape
and the the random or Brute Force
enumeration takes you to I don't know
depending on your result s two or three
maybe sometimes five uh thousand of
solved oi sequences like the the very
simple ones like constants identity some
linear uh functions Etc and from those
Solutions we we learn so so after we
verify them after we check that the
generated
program is really generating a
particular SE quence we create training
data for a machine learner we we have
tried different ones the the the one
that we have been running for longest
time is a very small language model
which actually isn't even a Transformer
it's an lsdm with attention which we can
train pretty quickly and also uh infer
with it really
quickly and uh once we have trained the
this smallish uh language model we use
it for better informed um generation so
so we train it on the examples which say
this integer sequence is explained by
this code and now once we have trained
it we take all the sequences the the
350,000 sequences in the oeis we give
them as an input to to the language
model and we ask it for many suggestions
like 240 uh suggestions of the programs
that could be explaining uh this this
sequence so so we get millions of
explanations and we very efficiently
verify them like we we try to see
whether they do explain some of the oi
sequences or not and if they do we we
train on them again so so that again G
gives us this kind of search
verification and learning uh feedback
loop and
this is kind
of
uh surprising
compared to to the feedback loop that I
was showing here where like like this
the improving feedback loops are typ
typically plateauing pretty early like
here after the six iterations it already
is doing quite a bit less than let's say
in the first
iteration well here it's it's really not
plateauing for a very long time and I
I'm kind of still thinking why it is I
one one conjecture why it could be like
this is that um it's doing basically two
kinds of learning here it's it's kind of
doing symbolic um inventions like like
for example when it invents the program
for
primes it uh it suddenly gets a huge
boost like like uh I don't know where it
was yeah you you can see these boosts
after it invents uh various uh
stuff and uh for example the program for
for primes is really important for
explaining many other sequences in the
online encyclopedia of inte sequences so
so my my conjecture is that this
feedback loop isn't hasn't really pled
for for 700
iterations because it has this
combination of making like some symbolic
U breakthroughs or or inventions and
sort of statistically propagating them
by by by the trained language model
which kind of once it learns something
it it sort of proposes it as explanation
for other sequences and if it gets
confirmed it it it gets a boost and uh
it gets propagated
further uh
the the the one interesting thing about
this is that that this experiment has
been extremely cheap like this cost us
like buy now maybe $3,000 on the on the
electricity because we really train like
very small language models and
also it has this alien aspect so for
example for primes we now have more than
50 different explanations some of them
are not primes some of them are pseudo
primes and some of them you really think
need need to think quite hard whether
they really are primes or Studio primes
so sometimes we really need to ask
mathematicians whether uh is is this is
this legal he here is a bit of a
bragging side what what you can do with
with this language so you can uh do
expansion of square root of eight and
base three you can do some of convey
$10,000 sequence that there is one
program short one for primes that I'm
showing here some elliptic curve wolf
froms 30,000 through 30 automaton and
very recently we we got the cube root of
two and I sent it to Tom hells and he
blocked about it so you can you can look
it up and these are kind of the
interesting jumps that you that you get
when when it invents uh something like
for example when it uh when it invented
primes it it it made the jump when it
U like invented square roots it it made
another jump etc etc so this is really
one one of the funniest feedback loops
that I have been running in in my life
oh here is one more so I I have talked
to a mathematician last years as under
Daman who is doing research in elliptic
curves and he told me to look at these
six otic curves so I looked it up and we
can solve the
three uh easiest ones that he proposed
to me and we cannot solve uh the the
other three that he gave me and again we
we none of us again it has this alien
aspect that neither he nor nor us
understand how how this co co code
works okay so so these are the two quick
um
intro demos to kind
of let you know what I'm uh talking
talking about uh the I have a slide
about the the history Etc so there is
this already things going back like
ponar hbert Russell liet
Etc
uh a very important or interesting guy
in in in the history of all of this is
obviously Turing who obviously invented
computers Pro the undecidability of
first all logic but but he also
basically started AI right like in in
his 1950s paper and even funnier thing
is that the last chapter of his 1950s
paper on AI is called learning Machin so
so if you think that machine learning is
something very new then then no like
it's it's been and he he even proposes
playing chess or some something that you
could have some learning
process there as I said
uh automated the improving has been
really one one of the first AI Fields
with people like I don't know Herbert
Simon Martin Davis etc etc U doing their
work in the 50s and and 60s and these
were really some of the first AI
systems uh you get people like Pat
Langley and
duut uh working for example automated
mathematicians on or like symbolic
learning of Kepler law in the case of
Pat
Langley uh then in the
90s there was a group that I already
mentioned like Stefan schs and the
dancing in Munich who really started to
think about combining machine learning
with automated the improving and it's
also very interesting because some of
the quote unquote celebrated deep
learning architectures to today like
three three neural networks were
invented by them when doing research
about automated improving because you
you work a lot with three structures
when when doing uh math right um so so
that that's been uh pretty influential
like I said my my master seases was to
try to learn the the symbolic programs
and inductive logic programming and I I
would say basically some like for some
25 years now some of us have been
playing in in this field of taking some
big math cpose and trying to to do these
combinations on that that there
is especially for the younger people I I
have watched it because I've been
exposed for such a long time in in on
the kind of intersection of these
communities how the buzz wordss are
changing uh so I don't know 10 years ago
people stopped saying machine learning
and started to say deep learning uh then
then five years ago they stopped saying
deep learning and started to say large
language models right maybe two years
ago they stopped saying large language
models and started to say AGI or it was
like so so if if you want to kind of get
deeper into these distinctions then that
there is a nice talk by Ben gzel who is
like the founder of the AGI conference
that he gave some six years ago in pra
and very kind of explains the the
distinctions between between all these
things oh I have a quick slide
about um the the Practical applications
of of of this work so uh that that has
been for some I don't know to today
let's say 15 years a pretty interesting
progress
in in this kind of Li nits dream thing
in in this uh in this idea that we will
really formally verify in in
logic a lot of the stuff of the at least
important stuff that we are doing so one
breakthrough was the formal proof of the
cap conjecture done by Tom ha like
that's been officially finished in
2014 and that there is a big big story
to it I will not go into it another one
was a formalization finished in 2012 of
the fight Thompson theorem which is like
the first big step towards the
classification of finite simple groups
uh by the team of George
gonier uh and there is much more of it
the the kind of industrial part of it is
that people have for example verified a
c compiler concert like the group of
xaviera in France and for example a very
interesting think is that several years
ago somebody did some some really pretty
strong testing of various C compilers
and this there is basically only one C
compiler which didn't produce any bucks
when when you when you kind of do some
fuzzing Etc and that's exactly the disc
comert that this kind of verified C
compiler so that kind of shows you the
the power of formal formal verification
life you have proved that that it works
then then it works like at least unless
unless you break some of the assumptions
right uh so so I would say since people
like Byron cook joined Amazon and
started to create the um really
industrial automated reasoning and
formal verification group applying
formal verific like like people like
John Harrison I for example verifying
the cryptographic protocols working on
your phone today uh so so in in the
recent years this this has really become
pretty industrially important also like
the field of formal verification and
obviously the the stronger and stronger
automated the improving tools we can
create for these people the the faster
this process right the faster the form
of verification and then there is this
book Sky AI Visions which I don't know
we are probably more interested in but
here but I already spoke about them uh I
will probably not not speak much about
learning approaches I I just sort of
gave here this one slide to to sort of
reiterate that um machine learning isn't
just statistical machine learning isn't
just deep neural networks isn't just
um language modules Etc so some people
even started to call
everything but deep learning classical
machine learning but that's total
nonsense because neural networks are one
of the most classical my machine
learning approaches so so so there are
really many many things that you can do
if you if you want to learn some some of
them are for example symbolic uh
algorithms that kind of learn a symbolic
uh
algorithm and I I guess that's some of
the stuff that might be close to to the
people
here and yeah yeah there is a lot of it
and I have no chance of going into it
but uh what is also interesting for
let's say understanding math or doing
some some kind of machine learning for
math is uh like thinking about how to
characterize mathematical objects and
again the the answer of De planning and
and the kind of breakthrough with de
planning is is basically saying we don't
care right like we will learn it end to
end we will have more and more layers
and they will do it all uh and it's
interesting how how well that works
right like how how how really what what
kind of interesting stuff you can you
can do today uh with the language moves
Etc on the other hand like I I guess
most of you here are mathematicians or
computer scientists so you you you know
that for example transform
has some clear computational limitations
right so so if you I don't know want it
to behave like a program then then you
can easily construct a program which
will not be learned by by a Transformer
right so so so then you can think about
I don't know more semantic or more
computational characterization of the
mathematical objects that you will feed
to to your machine Learners and
sometimes it's kind kind of necessary or
much more productive than than relying
on on some limited neural network to to
do something that is kind of impossible
uh for it so so it's it's a also like a
very interesting uh
topic uh here's an overview slide about
how like what are the various scenarios
how we combine learning with the
improving so so the oldest task which is
kind of easy and most tested today
it's called premise section is this kind
kind of high level high level thing
where you you get a big library of
mathematics you get a new conjecture to
prove and now if you fat the the full
mathematical Library which has I don't
know 100,000 or 1 million facts in it to
an automated theor Pro then the
automated theorem Pro wouldn't do much
because it has kind of an Expos
combinatorial search at least 20 years
ago so so what you can do how you can
help the automated a lot is that you
basically machine learn on the 100,000
proofs that you already have in the
library which tells you like how what
what facts are kind kind of relevant for
for for which uh conjectures and and
that allows you to
prune uh the the kind of much smaller
number of of the relevant facts for for
your new conjecture uh to uh to to to
try to to serve attempt the the CRM
quest uh so so that that's very
productive I may show you some pictures
uh later it's also kind of very easy for
people who want to try some more
expensive machine learning so so for
example the the first thing when I
started to talk to to the Deep learning
people like 10 years ago was this task
like this this premise selection because
you can train a huge deep learning
architecture and when you get a problem
you you run it just once it can take you
I don't know one second and then you run
the
fast through so you don't care that to
one one second right so so it's a good
domain for the Deep learning Al Etc
people oh then there there's this much
more ambitious task of like lowlevel
guidance of of the inference engines of
the automated F
ERS which is what I was showing you in
the very beginning like for example this
Enigma system where the ambition is
basically okay like this machine is
really doing a lot of modus pences or
resolutions or superpositions per second
and I want it to be smart right and and
then you cannot use something very
expensive but as you have seen you you
can do it with uh with sort of
reasonable machine learning tools then
the there's this midlevel uh thing where
it's it's today quite popular where it's
somewhere between the kind of low level
and the high level is it's especially
used in the Tactical theor and PR like I
know
cooline Etc where you you have bigger
blocks called tactics programmed in in
these tactical theorem provs and
typically to to do one longish proof you
would in invoke like 20 or 10 to to 100
of of these tactical
applications and that means you can
again use some more expensive
architecture so again it's it's a good
reasonable territory for uh the more
expensive uh thing then then you can do
these things like for example the
exploration where somebody gives you a
theory and now you are somehow supposed
to develop good lemas like like to
basically develop this this Theory so
that hasn't been done much yet but
people are getting to it there are all
these feedback loops and there is also
autof formalization which is this task
that we proposed some more than 10 years
ago now where you the the ambition is to
take something like a language model and
try to
train uh I mean translate let's say a
whole article written in latch into like
a formal setting and and see whether you
can verify it with with one of these
formal formal m systems so so again like
it's quite interesting for the people
doing language modes today I will not go
into these
demos uh I may mention a bit this uh
hammers which is like one of the biggest
applications of some some of the things
we are doing today so so you you have a
formal proof assistant it became popular
in Isabel which is a reasonably popular
proof
assistant uh and a system called sled
Hammer done by Larry pson and later just
Blanchett but basically today we have
hammers for almost all of the formal
proof assistants and the thing it's
doing is that it takes a
written in the logic of the proof
typically Som high of the logic or maybe
type Theory Etc it translates it to some
weaker logic like first order for
example it it runs a strong um solver
like like automated theor Pro in first
logic like e and if it solves the
problem then it tries to reconstruct the
proof and in the S stronger logic and
for for for that you you exactly this
need this task of premise selection like
to select the the facts that will make
it reasonably easy for the automated
theor proy and today this works so so
for example if you run Isabel if you are
sledgehammering in Isabel which is what
the Isabel people do quite quite a lot
basically you are issuing many many
queries to these automated theor
improvers and to these premise selectors
which are recommending different facts
according to to their knowledge so we
have roughly 40 to 45 success on a lot
of these libraries this this is from
2016 the the data from 2021 is 60% of me
are in in this kind of hammering
hammering
mode uh the the first feedback loop that
I did almost 20 years ago is this
malaria this machine learner for
automated reasoning which basically does
this premise selection combined with the
theorem proving in a feedback loop so so
it's kind of similar to this Enigma
feedback clue but in a simpler setting
when you are using just the premise
selector and here is sort of a recent
incarnation of it which my student did
couple of years ago where it's showing
um how the quality of the machine
learner influences the number of
problems solved in these feedback loop
so so so the better machine Learner in
this case the grade and boosted decision
threes is achiev more results uh in the
feedback loop than the old machine
learner and this is showing you another
interesting thing that is going on so
even though this feedback loop is sort
of pling which I already mentioned in
the beginning what is not pling is the
number of alternative proofs that we are
getting here so alternative proof is a
proof from different premises in this
case and uh you even though you are not
solving new problems you are still
getting new new proofs of them and it's
kind of an interesting task or problem
for for the machine Learners because you
somehow need to
decide what proofs you will be learning
from like if you have 20 or 100
different proofs of of the same problem
which proofs will you learn from all of
them some of them only one of them
Etc there is I should be wrapping up so
let me uh start skipping uh
things uh more uh so you you you can do
really a lot of stuff so for example one
of the stuff that I mentioned is that
you can use mod modelbased evaluation of
your effects in your
library as features for the machine
Learners so so that's something again
which you will not get with any neural
network today because the neural network
doesn't do combinatorial tasks like like
model or coun model finding so so that
pretty strongly improves the the premise
selection task you you can come up with
like various semantic um
features uh we we get a lot of Boost
from learning in a name independent
setting when we basically forget about
the names of the symbols and we just
look at the structural at the graphs of
the formulas which helps with the kind
of analogizing uh
task
uh I will skip this it's this is like
another simple Alpha zero
style uh lowlevel guidance
task uh which we which we it first in a
simplify setting uh this is about the
Enigma which I already showed you and
some additional effects about it I I
will
say again like we are playing with very
fast machine learning architectures for
example my my colleague Martin suda is
improving to today the best automated C
Empire by using very cheap three enal
metworks which basically only look at
the graph of derivations for for each
Clause they totally ignore what the
Clause is about and it's it's extremely
fast it's well integrated with how
vampire works and it's it's it's working
pretty pretty
well uh let me skip the M level stuff
yeah so I wanted to show you just one uh
of the ear least neural Auto
formalization things that we did with
shanik so so the autof formalization is
that you take latch and try to
automatically translate it
in this case to misar to to some formal
uh formal proest and format and so just
to kind of give you the feeling for it
this is how the data looks so so you get
the the latch and and you get the formal
uh formal language and this is how the
uh language model performed like six
years ago after various amount of
training so so initially when you didn't
train it too much if you give it as
input some some kind of latch it
produces gibberish but after like this
let's say 7,000 training steps at the
bottom it actually produces
legal legal
formal um language uh Mis uh input so so
this was done on synthetic data it kind
of doesn't imply that we have solved AO
formalization but but it shows you that
these SL Which models are pretty
interesting for for doing these tasks
like translating from informal to formal
I will skip conjecturing because I
already mentioned quite a bit I I can
say some cats comments and dark s sites
but maybe I will leave it to the
questions and this is the conference
that we have been running for 10 years
it's called artificial intelligence and
theor proving so if you're interested in
more of this please pleas come to Osa in
September that's
it a few minutes for questions who has a
question come on
questions um you have a question how
mathematical data is represented in mind
is this a psychological
question I have no
idea I I have no idea how how how we
represent mathematical data in our brain
well simplest case if set set
relations do you have
some hypthesis what kind of so so when
some mathematicians taught me math when
I was a student they they themselves
were commenting on this and they were
saying
oh for example I have a very geometric
um picture of it but there is that guy
who has a very algebraic symbolic uh
picture of it so so so for example this
this old Professor was saying that there
are very weird professors of mathematics
who have a very different representation
of of the mathematical problem than than
he would have oh so yeah I I don't know
we we need some neural link to to to do
some experiment on mathematicians
probably to thank you thank
you any more questions
yeah just bred by this question in fact
I'm a mathematician but I was reading a
neuroscience paper some time ago and
there was something about uh logical
deduction being rooted in a temporal
part of the brain whereas arithmetic is
in a spal visual part of the brain so
that seems to be fairly standard and one
question is when you do this uh well
symbolic representation of everything
everything is just the same so there is
no it's not very
humanlike right so uh maybe you don't
want it to be humanlike want to be
better than humans for certain tasks
but this makes you wonder whereas uh
Alien mathematics would be at all like
our mathematics if aliens are blind or
something so maybe they just develop
totally different things so this is an
open remark I I I was at some point
going to a foring Summoner and the the
the guys there seem to me like even
though set theory and and and this
forcing multivar
was something very symbolic it it looked
like they have really internalized it in
some weird way so I yeah I I I think
something definitely happens to a
mathematician who works in some domain
which looks very symbolic to to The
Outsiders but they they they still must
create some internal I know mental Maps
or yeah um yeah that's all I can
say um if we've just focus on the last
three years since uh the gpt3 came out
the what were the breakthroughs in this
area connected to the llm revolution is
there any that you like to mention so um
it's I my impression is that um people
have been trying to use llms more and
more for autof
formalization and uh like we we had a
VIR last spring in bone which was like
about bridging inal and formal math and
then when I was talking to to these
people who were kind of pushing ahead
with the the neural language models in I
think in the Isabel setting it it they
were kind of acknowledging that it's
it's not yet working spectacularly well
like it looks like I know if you if you
have a kind of a boring homogeneous
domain like like people are training it
for for this IMO for for this ma
Olympiad which however seems to be
pretty like some kind of high school
limited math and if you throw a lot of
training data in in this restricted
domains then it seems to be kind of
working to to some extent but if you go
to some kind of limited math like like
the Isabel full Archive of formal proofs
that then it still doesn't seem to be
cutting it but like you know the
development if is like you just a deep
seek last week right or whatever so so I
would say that that's One Direction
where people are pushing another
Direction which is also slightly
controversial is that people are pushing
a lot this llms in this kind of
mid-level guidance in this guidance of
lean Co whole Etc but again like um it's
it's you have to be cautious because
like my PhD student had recently a paper
for where they showed that the
speed is really important so so they
compared a very simple but fast machine
learning method like indexed Katey
sniper with the Transformer with with a
reasonably trained Transformer and they
showed that the K near sber which was
reasonably implemented and index because
it does search so much faster actually
ultimately outperforms the the guidance
by the large language models if you if
you kind of do the fair uh comparison of
it so I I would say people people are
trying uh and another obvious direction
is conjecturing right like if you like
like the first experiment I was showing
it's a very small language model I skip
the kind of GPT sty conjecturing which I
was doing long ago but like you you can
I know I was just running deep seek last
week when it appeared and it seems to be
doing pretty well I I gave it a task
which could could be quite hard for it
and it almost got it but it took it like
10 minutes on on the so so again like
the time the inference time is kind of
incompatible with the with the systems
we we are running but I I I think for
these things like like some kind of high
level
conjecturing it it could be it could be
pretty U interesting to to to try
because uh yeah well at least that's my
impression yeah